The thing you used to dread more than anything else was to take these out of the box in which you
carefully stacked them up
and then accidentally dropped them on the floor. There is no quicker way
to discover what n factorial means when you start trying to put them back together in the right order
Armed only with your knowledge of ALGOL programs and which order these things must have occurred in
We have here in the department a legacy deck of punch cards
dating at my best guess from about
1971 it was left behind by a
Statistic student of that era can act in it just is like a blast from the past
We'll put this on the classic black background provided by the cover of an iPad
What could be better old meets new?
At the top of the deck we used to have to put a colored card
Basically stating who we were and what this job was about
Now I think the first thing to draw your attention to on any sample of these cards is
You look at them against the light and if you remember that a card reader is reading
vertically to get its characters [boom]
Run like that not horizontally... The most amazing thing you then discover which threw me for a while because I'd rather forgotten
It works like this is that if you now put the card down on a black background
And will use another card as a ruler just look what happens every single
character and
if you look very carefully as
well as the whole pattern
That denotes a character it can also be printed out at the top of the card although the printing Ribbon was pretty faded without
these
nevermind every single character has got a
different hole punch pattern but there's never more than two holes that are punched. Now that might seem very strange
and as I say I gave me a jolt at all. How on Earth does that get
converted into a character code which is going to be a bit pattern representing an ASCII character
or whatever you can't just port ASCII
character punching down here if you did you get into all sorts of problems.
Because some ASCII characters have got lots of one bits in them
and if the situation is that you chose that every one bit was a hole
some characters would make this thing look like confetti. It would be like having a
terraform... you know the [beasts] [only] [holes]... that the actual mechanical substrate of the card will be very fragile
So this is the reason that there are
various choices of two holes here out of 11 rows in total
and that gives enough
combinations to give a
unique code for
a fairly limited
alphabet admittedly, but it works
So perhaps another thing to point out is that these are
cards for an
ICL 1900 computer which was mentioned in the previous video
The ICL 1900 series
internally did not hold its characters in 8 bits as would be done
nowadays. It held them in 6 bits
So pretty well all of you out there are familiar with the fact that nowadays if you like
the standard
for years has been that you have a computer
whose integers are held in 32 bits?
but if you want those 32 bit entities called words are broken up into
four 8-bit bytes
Nowadays, it's the bytes that are addressed not the words and that particular architecture of byte address machines been
optionally groupable into longer units to hold either
instructions or integers or whatever that really did start with IBM mainframes they were the first to go in for byte addressing and 8-bit bytes
ICL on the other hand did not have 32-bit words with four 8-bit characters it had
24-bit words with four 6-bit characters. Why are here you cry the answer is it's cheaper
You've got rather less memory to provide rather
simpler adders to do you only need 6-bit adder circuitry not 8-bit adder circuitry and
it's as simple as that
LCL could make their computers a little bit cheaper than IBM although they were arguably as well a little bit slower and so on
So this is what these hole punchings are all about.
They are equating
by specialized circuitry in the card reader to it being able to recognize these patterns and say oh
That's the 6 bit character such-and-such, and it will put that into a temporary file behind the scenes
Now when you're preparing these card decks you really did have to take huge care
First of all the yellow card announces that this is a job for the computer to do - big surprise there
There's a NUPMS
They're Nottingham (?) University Physics and Maths I think that stands for. This is ken's identifier
PMSKA for Ken Akin (?), and I think this thing at the end
announces the global terminator for this deck of cards which will come right at the bottom for our [perros]
Okay
Then there's a little piece of job control here
basically saying I want the Nottingham (?) University EXECutive program which was our own sort of
homebrew addition to ICL's GEORGE operating system
And you notice at the end here. It says BY C in this
added module to the operating system
You could say how desperately
urgent this job was or not. You were given a certain number of notional pounds to spend every month for every user.
And you could opt to spend less money and have it run at low priority
But you could either spend it by a which means
I want the job doing right now
Or you could say I'll go overnight and you were charged as a much lower rate. The next card we see here
announces that this is an ALGOL job, the following cards will be in the ALGOL language
So this is a signal to the operating system
though to read all this in but when it's been read in it has to be fed in to the ALGOL compiler and the
operating system knows where that's kept you don't
unlike
Unix Linux, whatever these days you don't get very close to the operating system. It's there
It doesn't do much for you except run your jobs
You just have to trust to it more or less
Notice here for those of you at all familiar with things like ALGOL and Pascal
It's beginning to look fairly sensible: BEGIN. That's a reserved word in the ALGOL language
It's a bit like open curly-brace ("{") in C
But ALGOL use BEGIN and END instead of
open curly ("")
Notice that it's signaled as being a reserved special word because it uses prime or
Single quote symbols, it's quote begin quote ('BEGIN')
Quote procedure quote ('PROCEDURE'). That's another reserved word in the ALGOL language
And it's defining this procedure E01AAA with these
formal parameters
or arguments.
There we are then you're sitting in front of a card punch you type in just like you would do on a
ordinary keyboard these days except this thing is electromechanical
So it's going to splash splash splash splash all the time. Every character you hit is punching out holes
electromechanically and at the same time is hammering out a typewriter record on the top of
exactly what all these holes mean.
Every time you hit the return key
whereas even on the dumb terminal you find the cursor going zonk back from
from the right hand side of the screen to the left as you look at it
what would happen when you hit return on one of these is that the card would as if by magic?
Be taken away from the punching station and propelled
I think with sort of compressed air to a catcher tray
So one after another you would build up a stack of cards in order
That would later be fed into the machine
So when it's all completed and of course the advantage is with having these things written out on top if you could see any mistakes on
a quick scan through you can always punch another card and replace the bad card with a good card
You would end up with a job to be submitted can stack is a particularly short one
It just seemed to be running this routine and using it to generate a small amount of data to be printed out
So there we are, a very very small job.
In order to stay sane
what you need to do is the following?
First of all decide whether your card punch like to have these beveled corners at the top left or top right
Faintly recall that ICL and IBM probably did them different ways around, but that was the thing to help you get your cards aligned and
stop you turning one accidentally upside down and
thereby reading in the wrong hole pattern in the wrong order
You used to make sure the bevels were
in place and like that, so that's one
self-protection mechanism
Another one that was optionally available on some better quality card punches with support at the far right of the card
typically, I think in columns 72 to 80 because these are 80-columned cards
You could put a sequencing number here, okay? You can have them automatically sequence the numbered as you
punch them out on the card punch
The thing you used to dread more than anything else was to take these out of the box
in which you carefully stacked them up and then accidentally dropped them on the floor
There is no quicker way to discover what n factorial means when you start trying to put them back together in the right order
armed only with your knowledge of ALGOL programs and which order these things must have occurred in
So all sorts of subterfuge is used to be used, but the best was to have them
numbered if possible and then if you could afford one of these things that were actually
card collecting machines where if you put in a randomized of cards they could electromechanically sort them for you
I can't recall I ever used one of those perhaps. I was careful enough or perhaps the university couldn't afford one
I don't know.
Another common trick to use which I'm actually port
marker pen markings at the top of these if you did or you wrote a word here
You could get them broadly back in the correct order by just making your patterns at the top look
correct and get them back in roughly the way they should have been. So here we have you see a much
more substantial
ALGOL job, I think most of this is programmed
there's a little bit of data at the bottom.
-So would you have one of these cards for every line?
would that be kind of...
- Every line of the program?
Yeah, would have a card.
-Line and you could only fit one line for your copy.
-Yeah, yeah, one lamp guard.
Right at the end of this lodge of stuff
Let's put it down here as a separate card of its own
you see that magic word END and that is the final end of the program
And just as in other languages you're open ("") can be nested inside each other
So also in ALGOL the BEGIN END blocks could be nested inside one another
So that END then is the final card of the program
But then look what happens you get a full asterisks card
The four asterisks is a marker to say that's the end of my program, but there's still another section of my stuff to come
After four asterisks you give the reserved word DATA and this is such a simple program
I think from what I can make out it takes these three integers here and
uses them to generate yet more data
which will be of use in some other programs, so
that is it. There's the data
that's the end of the pack. If you had a program that generated more data for input to another program a
favorite thing you could do was to specify in your job control at the very top that what you would like is
not just a line printer output of your answers, but to punch out another deck of cards
For use in putting it into some other program later on
-So that basically provides you with a set of data to use with a different [program]
Yes, and you might say well, why not just pocket in a disk file
You've got to remember. This is the early seventies. You did not have a personal
allocation of files on disk
Yes, then would be a disk backing up this computer
But use entirely by the operating system
Full of temporary files holding your jobs for you, feeding them in an order and all that, but in the very early days
You in person did not get a personal account to hold your files
You wanted to run something later on then you had to print it out
So whereas nowadays a lot of you know
if you want to punch out date for use another program you can either use a Unix pipe and pipe it
directly into another program or you can use the Unix greater than symbol and send it into a file
Much more complicated in these days you had to announce ahead of time that you would be punching out
results as well as printing them out
That's interesting. What would a computer do with a hanging Chad?
The admission of Richard Stallman's name was not intentional
I was thinking of him actually as I spoke
I was tempted for a while and many of my friends told me to try this on with you
But maybe not
It would tend that the compressed air
is a lot of compressed air used in these machines to move the cars through very quickly